so back to kind of the github workflow  you create a branch you make commits you  have a conversation and maybe add some  more commits what about when it's time  to bring your changes back into master  branch that's when you merge your branch  now there's a couple different ways to  do it in the pull request you can merge  directly on github.com so you would  merge on the remote bringing your  branches changes and commits on to this  master branch you can also merge locally  with git merge now merging by itself  isn't that complex of a topic but there  are a lot of different ways you can  merge and some problems you can run into  we'll get into those in some of our next  videos